From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台和公共广播国际台联合制作的《美国生活》节目。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
And this is the story of the day that my dad fired his mother and sent her home from work. With her 13 inch black and white TV in the passenger seat. As if a sure sign that she was definitely not coming back, she was taking the TV with her.
这是关于我父亲解雇他母亲，并把她赶出公司那天发生的故事。当时她把那台13英寸黑白电视机放在副驾驶座上带走了。仿佛是一个明确的信号：她再也不会回来了，她要把电视也一并带走。
There are two kinds of family stories, your tragedies and your comedies. This, you'll be glad to hear, is a comedy.
家庭故事通常分为两类：悲剧和喜剧。很高兴告诉你们，这是一个喜剧。
When Rory was growing up in Massachusetts, everybody in the family did some work for the family business, a machine shop. She and her sisters assembled tiny parts as kids at their kitchen table. Her grandfather ran the technical side. Her dad ran the business side.
罗里在马萨诸塞州长大时，家里每个人都在经营家族生意——一家机械车间。她和姐妹们小时候在厨房餐桌上组装微小的零件。她祖父负责技术方面，她父亲负责商业运营。
And my grandmother, my father's mother, was the secretary in the shop. She sat in the front with my father, like right outside his office. And he couldn't stand, basically, that she always gave him what he calls "chin music." Which is she would always be like, why are you paying that person that amount of money? Or why are you lending that person that money? It was always about money. It was always about the business affairs of the shop that she felt like she had to say something and that drove him bats.
而我的祖母，也就是我父亲的母亲，是车间的秘书。她坐在前台，就在我父亲办公室外面。他基本上无法忍受她总是对他“喋喋不休”。也就是说，她总是会问：“你为什么要付那个人那么多钱？”或者“你为什么要借钱给那个人？”话题总是围绕着钱。她总是觉得必须对车间的商业事务发表意见，这让他非常抓狂。
So one day, I guess he had asked her to order a bunch of liquor for a party. I think it was like a wintertime party, possibly a Christmas party. And it was a list of all the liquor that they needed to get. And she thought that there was too much gin on the list. She thought that gin was a summer drink, despite the fact that she doesn't drink. And so she said to my father, don't you think that that's too much gin? You should order something else or don't get that. Don't get that drink. And he said, no, we're going to get that. Just order what I wanted. And she sort of went at him again, I think. And then, as she says, it just grew into something much uglier.
所以有一天，我想他让她为一场聚会订购一批酒。我记得那好像是一个冬天的聚会，可能是一个圣诞派对。那是一份他们需要购买的酒水清单。她觉得清单上的金酒太多了。尽管她自己不喝酒，但她认为金酒是夏天喝的。于是她对我父亲说：“你不觉得金酒太多了吗？你应该订点别的，或者别买那个。别买那个酒。”他说：“不，我们就买那个。只要照我说的订就行。”我想她可能又对他唠叨了几句。然后，正如她所说的，事情演变成了一场更糟糕的冲突。
I guess, basically, he just threw in her face that she was always second-guessing everything that he did. That drove him bats and he told her, basically, to get out.
我想基本上他就是当面指责她总是质疑他所做的每一件事。这让他抓狂，他基本上就是让她走人。
Of course, second guessing is part of what being a parent is all about. You're supposed to second-guess your kids' decisions when they're little. And then, after 15, 20 years, who among us is so strong that they could just suddenly stop? It happens without thinking, without you even wanting it to. Your kid does something. You automatically calculate, is that the right thing or not? You can't just leave it aside because you and your kid happen to be at work.
当然，质疑也是为人父母的一部分。当孩子还小的时候，你应该质疑他们的决定。然后，在15、20年后，我们之中有谁能强大到突然停止这种行为呢？这会在你不知不觉中发生，甚至在你不想这样做的时候。你的孩子做了一些事，你会自动计算：这是正确的做法吗？你不能仅仅因为你和孩子正好在工作场所就把它抛在一边。
And then, of course, there's the kid's side. Who wants to be second-guessed like that all the time? Some estimates say that 40% to 60% of our nation's gross domestic product is created by family businesses. And you just have to wonder, how? How is our economy holding together?
当然，还有孩子那一面。谁想一直被那样质疑？一些估计显示，我国40%到60%的国内生产总值是由家族企业创造的。你不得不怀疑，怎么会这样？我们的经济是如何维持的？
I would definitely wager that some of those families, I think that they probably become coworkers more than family. I mean that's just my guess. So I can imagine it. I think it's definitely like making money is more important than getting along at a certain point.
我敢肯定，在这些家庭中，他们可能更像同事而不是家人。我是说，这只是我的猜测。所以我能想象出来。我觉得在某种程度上，赚钱肯定比和睦相处更重要。
Excuse me?
你说什么？
Isn't that the way it should be?
难道不应该是这样吗？
Now there's a big family values thought for all of us to share today.
现在，这真是一个值得我们今天分享的宏大“家庭价值观”观点。
In Rory's family, everybody forgave or forget within a week after her father fired her mother. But other families aren't so civilized. Today on our program, stories of family businesses. What happens when the tension of family dynamics collides with the pressure of capitalist market forces? It's money, intrigue, blood, everything. Act One of our program, What's a Grecian Urn? David Rakoff takes us inside the world of one Greek family restaurant. Act Two, Silent Partner. A family that started a family business because grief counseling didn't work. Because time did not heal. Because nothing else to seemed to solve their problem. Act Three, Family Photo Opp. Dave Eggers and what happens when politics suddenly becomes your family business. When your brother runs for office spouting political views that you do not usually agree with yourself. Act Four, Every Unhappy Family Cleaning Supplies Business is Unhappy in Its Own Way. We hear how an invitation to a business meeting sent through the mail in 1963 kept two sides of a family from speaking with each other for most of the second half of the 20th century. Stay with us.
在罗里的家庭里，在她父亲解雇母亲后的一周内，大家都原谅或忘记了这件事。但其他家庭就没有那么文明了。今天我们的节目将讲述家族企业的故事。当家庭关系的紧张与资本市场力量的压力碰撞时，会发生什么？这关乎金钱、阴谋、血缘，应有尽有。本节目第一幕，《什么是希腊瓮？》，大卫·拉科夫将带我们深入一家希腊家庭餐厅的世界。第二幕，《沉默的合伙人》，一个家庭因为悲伤咨询无效，因为时间没有治愈伤痛，因为似乎没有什么能解决他们的问题，于是他们创办了一家家族企业。第三幕，《家庭合影》，戴夫·艾格斯将讲述当政治突然成为你的家族生意时会发生什么——当你的兄弟竞选公职，并发表你通常并不认同的政治观点时。第四幕，《每个不幸的清洁用品生意家庭都有其各自的不幸》，我们将听到1963年一封寄出的商业会议邀请函如何导致一个家庭的两派在20世纪下半叶的大部分时间里互不交谈。请继续收听。
Act One, What's a Grecian Urn? Writer David Rakoff says that every job that he's ever had was for a family business of one sort or another. They've usually been hot beds of family intrigue and melodrama. Except at one place where he worked as a teenager, where it was only in retrospect that he fully understood what had been going on around him among family members every day.
第一幕，《什么是希腊瓮？》。作家大卫·拉科夫说，他做过的每一份工作都是某种形式的家族企业。它们通常是家庭阴谋和情节剧的温床。除了他青少年时期工作过的一个地方，在那里，直到事后他才完全明白当时在家庭成员之间每天都在发生什么。
King Constantine the Second, the deposed monarch of Greece, was passionate about my French vanilla root beer floats. The French vanilla was definitely one of our better flavors. We charged $0.05 more per scoop. Not every ice cream parlor in Toronto in the summer of 1982 came equipped with lapsed royalty. But Athos and Melina, the married couple who owned the shop where I worked, were old friends of the king. They had known him ever since the good old days when Constantine was still ensconced in happy figurehead-hood, and when Athos and Melina were at the tippy-top of Athenian society, he, a drug company executive, she, a scientist in the perfume industry.
被废黜的希腊君主康斯坦丁二世曾对我的法式香草根汁汽水情有独钟。法式香草绝对是我们最好的口味之一。我们每勺多收5美分。在1982年夏天的多伦多，并不是每家冰淇淋店都有落难皇室成员光顾。但阿索斯和梅琳娜，这对拥有这家店的夫妇，是国王的老朋友。他们从康斯坦丁还在享受幸福的挂名君主时期就认识他了，那时阿索斯和梅琳娜正处于雅典社会的巅峰，他是制药公司高管，她是香水行业的科学家。
The sense one got was that this was a couple on the lam for some reason. From Athens, they had fled to the Sudan, where they continued their rarefied lifestyle. And where a few years later, the volatile politics of that region would send them into flight yet again, landing them here in Toronto, exhausted and vaguely punch-drunk, the stunned franchisees of a well known ice cream parlour chain. Regrouping, they settled into their new lives in this ersatz San Francisco gold rush saloon, with its faux Tiffany lamps, frosted mirrors, and wrought iron chairs. It was an aesthetic so relentless and so forced in its attempt to evoke those bygone days in the city by the bay, that it even went so far as to name its biggest and most vulgar sundae after a civic disaster where thousands upon thousands of San Franciscans were killed.
人们给人的感觉是，这对夫妇因为某种原因在逃亡。他们从雅典逃到了苏丹，在那里继续他们高雅的生活。几年后，该地区动荡的政治局势又迫使他们再次逃离，最终落脚在多伦多，疲惫不堪且有些精神恍惚，成了知名冰淇淋连锁店的尴尬加盟商。他们重新振作，在这个仿造的旧金山淘金热沙龙里安定下来，那里有仿蒂芙尼灯、磨砂镜子和锻铁椅子。这种审美在努力唤起旧金山海湾城市往昔岁月的尝试中表现得如此刻意且强硬，甚至把店里最大、最俗气的圣代命名为一场导致成千上万旧金山人丧生的城市灾难。
I know a special birthday boy. Will you be having the earthquake?
我认识一个特别的寿星。你要来一份“地震”吗？
Imagine, if you will, Marie Antoinette, who instead of succumbing to the decapitory charms of the guillotine, is safely spirited away from France to England along with other fortunate aristocrats. Now resettled, she runs a fish and chips stand in Brighton, where daily the tiny, golden ship perched in the frothy waves of her high-powdered wig regularly topples into the deep fat fryer. This will give you a sense of how profoundly strange was Athos and Melina's presence in our midst.
想象一下，如果玛丽·安托瓦内特没有屈服于断头台的诱惑，而是和其他幸运的贵族一起被安全地从法国转移到英国。现在她重整旗鼓，在布莱顿开了一个炸鱼薯条摊，每天她那高耸的假发波浪中插着的小金船，都会摇摇欲坠地掉进深油炸锅里。这让你能感觉到阿索斯和梅琳娜出现在我们中间是多么深刻地离奇。
Athos looked like a latter day Jean Paul Belmondo, a formerly handsome man whose features have gone rubbery and heavy with age. He was, for the most part, a surly, taciturn man, constantly trying to bilk us out of our near minimum wages by suddenly pretending to understand less English than he actually did. But despite his gruff manner, y chromosome, and ultimate control of our salaries, it was no secret who was truly in charge: Melina. Formidable, fire hydrant-sized Melina.
阿索斯看起来像晚年的让-保罗·贝尔蒙多，一个曾经英俊的男人，但随着年龄增长，五官变得松弛而沉重。他基本上是一个粗鲁、沉默寡言的人，总是试图通过假装听不懂英语来克扣我们那点微薄的工资。但尽管他态度粗暴、身为男性且最终掌控我们的薪水，但谁才是真正的主宰并非秘密：梅琳娜。那是令人生畏的、消防栓一般身材的梅琳娜。
If she had ever decided to withhold our payment, she would have never resorted to falsely broken English. She would have simply told us outright. I adored her. She was smart as a whip, possessed of an appreciative and often bawdy sense of humor, and sounded not a little bit like Peter Laurie. She was also prone to moods so changeable-- from borderline inappropriate affection to homicidal seething rage in mere seconds-- that one gave up trying to guess her mental state and surrendered to the hurricane of emotion that was Melina.
如果她决定扣发我们的工资，她永远不会使用蹩脚的英语。她会直接告诉我们。我崇拜她。她聪明绝顶，有一种充满欣赏且常常下流的幽默感，说话听起来有点像彼得·洛。她还容易情绪化——在几秒钟内从近乎不适当的亲昵转变为致命的汹涌怒火——让人放弃猜测她的精神状态，只能臣服于梅琳娜的情绪风暴中。
Actually, Athos and Melina weren't even really aristocrats. They were meritocrats. Their position in that world of Levantine glamour from which they had been lately cast out was earned by dint of study, expertise, and labor. They definitely knew the meaning of hard work.
事实上，阿索斯和梅琳娜甚至不是真正的贵族。他们是精英。他们在那个他们最近被逐出的地中海魅力世界中的地位，是靠学习、专业知识和劳动赢得的。他们绝对懂得努力工作的意义。
We all sought refuge in the back. The kitchen became a haven for us. It was the place where they kept the industrial-sized tank of nitrous oxide used to make the whipped cream.
我们都寻求躲进后方。厨房成了我们的避风港。那是他们存放用于制作鲜奶油的工业级氧化亚氮罐子的地方。
As anyone who has ever worked in an ice cream parlor can tell you, two things end up happening really quickly. You get sick of ice cream almost immediately. And soon thereafter, you fall in love with nitrous oxide. You heart whippets.
正如任何在冰淇淋店工作过的人所说，两件事会很快发生：你几乎立刻就对冰淇淋感到厌倦，随后你就会爱上氧化亚氮。你迷上了这种“鞭子”（笑气）。
This ardor eventually cools when you realize that it's been weeks since you've been able to subtract simple sums, use an adjective correctly, or spell your own last name. But at the first blush of narcotic romance, you merely wonder where whippets have been all your life.
这种狂热最终会冷却，当你发现已经几周无法进行简单的加减运算、无法正确使用形容词或拼写自己的姓氏时。但在第一次接触这种麻醉浪漫时，你只会想：我这辈子一直都在哪儿错过了这个？
We were frequently joined in our daily worship at the nozzle by Melina and Athos' son, Nick. I was desperate to be Nick.
梅琳娜和阿索斯的儿子尼克经常加入我们在气罐喷嘴旁的日常“崇拜”。我渴望成为尼克。
In 1982, I was valiantly trying to manifest as alternative, eccentric, divo. Instead, with my hair in a short back and sides do with a long and floppy neuromantic quiff on top, framing a face of such poorly concealed sweetness and naivete, I looked about as threatening and alternative as a baby poodle, as complicated as one of the ice cream cones I spent my days scooping.
1982年，我勇敢地试图表现出非主流、怪癖、男高音的样子。然而，我留着那种后侧剪短、头顶带着蓬松大背头的发型，框着一张掩饰不住天真和纯洁的脸，看起来既没有威胁也不够另类，就像一只小贵宾犬，复杂程度就像我每天舀的那种冰淇淋甜筒。
But Nick. Nick had perfected that epoche brand of [UNINTELLIGIBLE] with his eyelids at the perpetual half mast of weary disdain, his two-tone spiky hair and tapered jeans. Athos and Melina seemed as oblivious to his silent truculence as they were to each other.
但尼克不一样。尼克完善了那种典型的冷漠，他的眼睑永远处于一种厌世的不屑状态，还有他的双色刺猬头和修身牛仔裤。阿索斯和梅琳娜似乎对他的沉默抗议和对彼此的冷漠一样浑然不觉。
If the front of the store was their putative living room, where they didn't feel the need to talk to one another except in the presence of company, then the kitchen in back was Nick's domain, where they almost never ventured. The teenage bedroom of one's dreams. Namely, one with a working refrigerator, a six foot tall tank of pressurized mind-altering gas, and a gaggle of stoners to laugh at everything you say. Athos and Melina's complacent disregard of their son seemed yet more proof of their European sophistication.
如果店的前厅是他们的名义客厅，除了有客人在场，他们甚至觉得没必要互相交谈，那么后厨就是尼克的领域，他们几乎从不涉足。那是每个人梦想中的青少年卧室。也就是说，拥有一个能工作的冰箱、一个六英尺高的压缩致幻气体罐，以及一群会对你说的任何话大笑的“瘾君子”。阿索斯和梅琳娜对自己儿子漠不关心的态度，似乎进一步证明了他们的欧洲式世故。
Aside from occasionally working the register, Nick slouched about curating the music, a seemingly constant running loop of Big Science by Laurie Anderson, giving special play to its hit song, "O Superman," with its obligato of metronomic aspirating laughter. But his true pride and joy was his self-published punk new wave magazine, Before and After Science. It was a cut and paste affair of black and white checkerboard backgrounds, ransom note typography, and sci-fi movie chicks in beehive hairdos with cats eye glasses.
除了偶尔在前台帮忙，尼克总是懒洋洋地在那儿编排音乐，背景里循环播放着劳瑞·安德森的《大科学》，特别是主打歌《哦，超人》，伴随着机械节奏的笑声。但他真正的骄傲是他自办的朋克新浪潮杂志《科学之前与之后》。这是一种剪贴风格的刊物，有着黑白棋盘格背景、勒索信式的排版，以及带着猫眼眼镜留着蜂窝发型的科幻电影女郎。
It was available for sale at the front of the store at a cost of $5 for the premiere and, what was to sadly be, only issue. I think I'm the only person who bought a copy. But still, the pile of magazines provided a welcome counterpoint to the maudlin boosterism that invaded the store that summer. It was dubbed the summer of Annie by proclamation of the head office in honor of the release of the musical film adaptation of the Broadway show. Franchisees across North America had been encouraged to invest in Annie ice cream, a special tie-in flavor.
这本杂志在店前台有售，售价5美元，是创刊号，也是悲哀的唯一一期。我想我是唯一买过的人。但尽管如此，这堆杂志为那个夏天侵入店里的伤感励志氛围提供了一个受欢迎的反衬。由于音乐剧电影《安妮》的上映，总公司将其定名为“安妮之夏”。北美各地的加盟商都被鼓励投资“安妮冰淇淋”，一种特别的联动口味。
Annie ice cream was a noxious combination of strawberry and marshmallow, of such a vile and diabetic coma-inducing nature that it was too cloying even for its target market of little girls. Seven and eight year old angels would skip into the store, all pigtails and horse love, and the scales would fall from their eyes as they spied the pink and white tubs of Annie, seeing the concoction for what it was, insidious marketing, a pernicious inducement to submit to the patriarchy. These apple-cheeked youngsters became suddenly hardened and cynical. They took up smoking right there on line, laughing bitterly like baby [? peofs ?], derisively ordering futility shakes and double scoops of alienation chip. Or, perhaps memory exaggerates just a tad.
“安妮冰淇淋”是草莓和棉花糖的一种恶心组合，其卑劣程度足以让人陷入糖尿病昏迷，即便对目标客户——小女孩们来说，也太腻了。七八岁的小天使们扎着辫子、骑着木马蹦蹦跳跳地跑进店里，当她们看到那粉白色的“安妮”桶时，眼中的光彩瞬间消失，她们看穿了这所谓的配方不过是阴险的营销、一种逼迫她们服从父权制的有害诱惑。这些红扑扑脸蛋的孩子瞬间变得世故且愤世嫉俗。她们直接在排队时抽起烟来，苦笑着像微小的成年人，讥讽地要“徒劳奶昔”和“异化芯片双球”。或者，也许我的记忆稍微有点夸大其词了。
Available along with the ice cream and stacked into a doomed unpurchased pyramid were the Annie glasses. Drinking glasses emblazoned with the movie's logo and the likeness of Aileen Quinn, the little girl chosen in a nationwide search to portray the plucky iris and pupil-deprived orphan. Sales of these would benefit local charities. Even this altruism was not enough to move a single tumbler.
随冰淇淋一起供应并堆成注定卖不出去的金字塔形状的是“安妮玻璃杯”。杯子上印着电影标志和爱琳·奎恩的肖像，她是全国海选出的饰演那位机灵、缺乏父母关爱的孤儿的小女孩。这些杯子的销售收益将捐给当地慈善机构。即便这种利他主义也不足以卖出一个杯子。
Melina employed her usual unctuous tricks. Are you wearing Anais Anais, madam, she would coo. Ah, yes. It's a lovely fragrance. I was one of the chemists who created it in Paris. Yes, thank you so much. Can I interest you in one of our Annie glasses? Of course, it's for charity. No? That's perfectly fine. I thank you, madam. Good day. Wheeling around the instant the door closed she would hiss at us.
梅琳娜用她惯用的奉承招数。“您用的是安娜苏吗，女士？”她会轻声细语。“啊，是的。真是种可爱的香味。我就是在巴黎创造这种香水的化学家之一。是的，非常感谢。我能向您推荐一款安妮玻璃杯吗？当然，这是为了慈善。不要？完全没问题。谢谢您，女士。再见。”门关上的瞬间，她会转身对着我们嘶吼：
Did you see the jewels dripping off of that woman and she would not even buy one Annie glass. This is a film directed by John Huston, the man who made The Maltese Falcon. What is wrong with you people?
“你看到那个女人身上滴着珠宝了吗？她连一个安妮杯都不买。这可是约翰·休斯顿执导的电影，他可是拍过《马耳他之鹰》的人！你们这些人到底有什么毛病？”
We laughed, imitating her behind her back as I am doing now. But of course, Melina's rages had nothing to do with your customers' lack of appreciation for the [UNINTELLIGIBLE] of John Huston. At the age of 17, I was too young to smell the tang of flop sweat in the shop air. That smell of exertion that comes from trying to keep away the wolves of defeat. Looking back now, I can see in Melina's pendulum mood swings the desperation of a woman running out of ground beneath her feet where she could resettle and start over yet again.
我们大笑着，像我现在这样在背后模仿她。但当然，梅琳娜的愤怒与顾客对约翰·休斯顿作品的缺乏欣赏毫无关系。17岁时，我还太年轻，闻不到店里空气中那种失败带来的焦灼气味。那种试图挡住失败之狼的努力所散发的汗味。现在回想起来，我能从梅琳娜反复无常的情绪波动中看到一个女人的绝望，她在这个世界上已无立足之地，无法再次重新开始。
It must have seemed so foolproof to them, an American ice cream parlour. And so close to America. And how perfect too, that summer's thematic undercurrent, the unloved cartoon urchin with her little mongrel, delivered from abandonment and privation to a life of love and untold riches. Nick's magazine might almost have been the story of their family, before and after science. Before was their tenure in the reliable field of chemistry where something as ethereal and intangible as a fragrance could be created through the sober logic of a recipe. After was this random, anarchic world of business, a world that was failing them.
这对他们来说一定看起来天衣无缝，一家美式冰淇淋店。而且离美国如此之近。那个夏天的主题底色——那个被遗弃的卡通顽童和她的小杂种狗，从贫困与被遗忘中被拯救，从此过上充满爱和无尽财富的生活——这一切是多么完美。尼克的杂志简直就像是他们家庭的故事：《科学之前与之后》。之前是他们在可靠的化学领域的任期，在那里，像香味这样空灵无形的东西可以通过配方的清醒逻辑被创造出来。之后是这个随机、无政府主义的商业世界，一个正在抛弃他们的世界。
A year later, away at college, I would be sent a small newspaper item. The story between the lines made only sadder by the clinical dispassion of the clipping. A precipitous disappearance, no forwarding address, thousands of dollars in loans and bills outstanding, a shuttered store with no plans to reopen, a sheriff's department notice of seizure taped to the window.
一年后，我在大学里收到了一则简短的报纸新闻。字里行间的故事因为剪报那种临床般的冷漠而更加令人悲伤。突然的失踪，没有转发地址，成千上万的欠款和账单，一家关门且没有任何重开计划的商店，窗户上贴着治安官部门的查封通知。
If I look carefully, I can see them on an airplane. Athos sleeps. Nick tampers with the smoke detector in the bathroom, so he can light up. And there is Melina's face at the small round window. Shielding her eyes against the glass, she stares out into the light, past the blinking wing lights, past the western edge of the continent, out over the ocean, scanning the horizon for the next piece of dry land.
如果仔细看，我能看到他们坐在飞机上。阿索斯在睡觉。尼克在洗手间篡改烟雾探测器，以便能抽烟。梅琳娜的脸贴在小圆窗上。她遮住双眼抵挡玻璃上的光，盯着灯光外看，越过闪烁的机翼灯，越过大陆的西缘，越过大洋，扫描着地平线寻找下一块干燥的土地。
David Rakoff. His new book, Don't Get Too Comfortable, comes out this September.
大卫·拉科夫。他的新书《别太自在》将于今年九月出版。
[MUSIC- "HARD KNOCK LIFE (GHETTO ANTHEM)" BY JAY-Z]
[音乐：Jay-Z的《Hard Knock Life (Ghetto Anthem)》]
Act Two, Silent Partner. Now in this story of another family business, Sean Cole visited Chad's Trading Post, a restaurant filled with frilly knick knacks in Southampton, Massachusetts.
第二幕，《沉默的合伙人》。在另一个关于家族企业的故事里，肖恩·科尔走访了位于马萨诸塞州南安普顿的“查德的贸易站”，一家装满花哨装饰品的餐厅。
The first my girlfriend Mary Ellen and I walked into Chad's Trading Post, she noticed that only boys worked there and thought it was weird. Normally, she said, in a place like this, a small country restaurant, you only see girls working. She pointed to the cover of the menu, which read "Dedicated to and operated proudly in the memory of Chad D. McDonald, 3/12/74 to 3/11/90."
我和女友玛丽·埃伦第一次走进“查德的贸易站”时，她注意到只有男员工在工作，觉得很奇怪。她说，像这样的小型乡村餐厅，通常只有女孩在工作。她指着菜单封面，上面写着：“谨以此纪念查德·D·麦克唐纳（1974年3月12日至1990年3月11日），并以此为傲地运营。”
She leaned in to me and whispered, do you think the owner hires only boys because they remind her of her son? I certainly thought this was possible and sad in a way that makes you feel embarrassed for that person. Then a man came over and poured us some coffee. And when he turned around, there, in huge white letters on the back of his blue polo shirt, it said, "Chad's Brother."
她凑近我耳边低语：“你觉得店主只雇佣男孩是因为他们让她想起自己的儿子吗？”我确实觉得这有可能，而且这以一种让你为那个人感到尴尬的方式令人难过。接着一个男人走过来给我们倒咖啡。当他转身时，他那件蓝色Polo衫背后印着巨大的白色字母：“查德的兄弟”。
Do you think that's what they call all the managers here, I asked Mary Ellen. Do you think that's really Chad's brother?
“你觉得这叫店里所有经理的称呼吗？”我问玛丽·埃伦。“你觉得那真的是查德的兄弟吗？”
Then another friendlier manager type came over and asked us how we were doing and if we needed more coffee. And I noticed his shirt.
然后另一个更友善的经理走了过来，问我们感觉如何，是否需要更多咖啡。我注意到了他的衬衫。
My shirt says, "Chad's Best Friend." Logo over on the right-hand side. And it just tells the customers who we are. You got "Chad's Best Friend," you got "Chad's Brother," "Chad's Dad." And we had "Chad's Mom," too. But she's doing other things.
“我的衬衫上写着‘查德最好的朋友’。右边有标志。它只是告诉顾客我们是谁。你有‘查德最好的朋友’，你有‘查德的兄弟’，‘查德的父亲’。我们之前也有‘查德的母亲’。但她现在在做别的事。”
This is the story of Chad's Trading Post. From the time he was 12, Chad and his brothers and a few friends had always talked about starting a small restaurant together when they graduated high school. They had planned out menus, Chad's father took him looking for locations. But Chad died in a shooting accident two days before his 16th birthday. Chad's father, Glenn, his brothers Scott and Cory, and his best friend, Mike, tell the story.
这就是“查德的贸易站”的故事。从12岁起，查德和他的兄弟们以及几个朋友就一直讨论高中毕业后一起开一家小餐馆。他们规划了菜单，查德的父亲带他寻找店址。但在16岁生日前两天，查德死于一场枪击意外。查德的父亲格伦、兄弟斯科特和科里，以及他最好的朋友迈克讲述了这个故事。
The boy who shot and killed my son was his younger brother's best friend.
“开枪打死我儿子的那个男孩，是他弟弟最好的朋友。”
It was myself and my best friend at the time and Chad. And they were cleaning up the cellar for his birthday. Oh, you were there too.
“当时就是我和我最好的朋友，还有查德。他们正在打扫地下室准备过生日。哦，你当时也在。”
Yeah, we were in the kitchen cooking sausage.
“是的，我们在厨房烤香肠。”
But they were downstairs cleaning, and I was upstairs. My mother had just left. And me and Cory were upstairs cooking dinner. And they came up for a break, went in the room. And then we heard like a little firecracker go off. Then the person came out of the room. He had blood on his hands. And he's freaking out. I shot Chad. I shot Chad.
“但他们在楼下打扫，我在楼上。我母亲刚走。我和科里在楼上做饭。他们上来休息，进了房间。然后我们听到像鞭炮一样的声音。接着那个人从房间里出来，手上沾着血。他吓坏了，大喊：‘我开枪打了查德！我开枪打了查德！’”
The official ruling which was that Chad picked up a gun, pointed it at this fellow, said bang. The other fellow picked up a gun, pointed it back at Chad, pulled the trigger, and that was all.
官方裁定是：查德拿起枪指着那个人说“砰”。那个人拿起枪指回查德，扣动了扳机，就是这样。
So I called 911, then I paged my mother, and then the police got there.
“所以我打了911，然后传呼了我母亲，接着警察就到了。”
I was charged for involuntary manslaughter because it was my handgun that ultimately killed Chad, and that I was not aware that he had two of my handguns out of my cabinet in his bedroom at the time. And frankly, that was something I should have been aware of.
“我被控过失杀人，因为最终杀死查德的是我的手枪，而我当时并没有意识到他从我卧室的柜子里拿走了我的两把手枪。老实说，那是我应该意识到的。”
In 1993, the year Chad would have graduated from high school, the year he and Mike and his brothers and his father had planned to open a restaurant, they decided to open Chad's Trading Post.
1993年，也就是查德本该高中毕业的那年，也是他和迈克、兄弟们及父亲计划开餐馆的那年，他们决定开设“查德的贸易站”。
This is Chad's corner of the restaurant. Notice the menu board. It tells you to "Welcome to Chad's Trading Post Family Restaurant." It says, "Nobody leaves hungry" and lists all the specials of the day. It also has a claimer on the bottom that it's named in memory of Chad D. McDonald, and the date of his birth, which is 3/12/74.
这是餐厅的“查德角落”。注意菜单板。上面写着“欢迎来到查德的贸易站家庭餐厅”。写着“没人会饿着离开”，并列出了每日精选。底部还有一行声明，说明它是为了纪念查德·D·麦克唐纳，并标注了他的出生日期：1974年3月12日。
In all of the interviews I've ever heard and seen of an emotional nature, the person answering questions doesn't begin to cry until well into the interview. Chad's dad began crying before I even turned on my tape recorder. I asked him for a quick tour of the restaurant.
在我听过和看过的所有情绪类采访中，受访者通常要到采访后半段才会哭泣。查德的父亲在我打开录音机之前就开始哭了。我请他带我参观一下餐厅。
It's a nice place. Homey, even froufy, though all the men who created it are tattooed, muscly, working class guys, Chad's father included.
这是一个很棒的地方。温馨，甚至有点花哨，尽管所有参与创建它的男人们都是有纹身、肌肉发达的工薪阶层，包括查德的父亲。
To the left of that, shows you the last and most recent picture of my son, which was taken about six weeks before he died. And the picture of the two boys that were named in memory of him, his younger brother's son, who is Ian Chadwick, and his best friend's son who is named Chad Michael.
“在那左边，是我儿子最近的一张照片，是在他去世前六周拍的。还有两个以他名字命名的男孩的照片，一个是查德弟弟的儿子，叫伊恩·查德威克；另一个是他最好朋友的儿子，叫查德·迈克尔。”
This photo originally showed the two babies in Glenn's arms. But they had the photographer alter the photo and insert Chad's head over Glenn's.
这张照片最初显示的是格伦怀里的两个婴儿。但他们让摄影师修改了照片，把查德的头贴在了格伦的位置。
And what they did was took the picture and replaced, by computer, Chad's picture over mine. It's actually my arms holding them, but the rest of it's all Chad.
“他们所做的是用电脑把照片替换了。其实那是我怀里抱着他们，但其余的部分全是查德。”
Glenn showed me a painting in another corner of the restaurant. It was the comedy and tragedy masks from the cover of Motley Crue's album, Theatre of Pain, Chad's favorite record. After he died, Chad's friends and brothers adapted the design into a memorial to him. It appears on their shirts. Two brass masks hang over the door smiling and frowning. A huge flag with the masks hangs in the breeze outside, too heavy to flutter. Chad's brother, Scott, calls them the faces.
格伦向我展示了餐厅另一角的一幅画。那是Motley Crue乐队专辑《痛苦剧场》封面上的喜剧和悲剧面具，那是查德最喜欢的唱片。他死后，查德的朋友和兄弟们将这个设计改编成了纪念他的标志。它出现在他们的衬衫上。两个黄铜面具挂在门上，一哭一笑。一面巨大的印着面具的旗帜挂在室外微风中，太重了，无法飘动。查德的兄弟斯科特称它们为“面孔”。
This was my first tattoo I got, the comedy and tragedy faces with the in memory of Chad banner. And that was my first tattoo. And I got that for the obvious reason. That's pretty much the family symbol now. It started off with my father getting-- because this was the tattoo he wanted to get without the banners. But that's what he wanted to get. That's what he planned on getting the following year for his birthday. He already had it planned out.
“这是我纹的第一个纹身，喜剧和悲剧面孔，加上‘纪念查德’的横幅。那是我第一个纹身。我纹这个原因很明显。这基本上成了家庭象征。起初是我父亲想要纹——因为他本来就想纹这个，不要横幅。但他确实想纹这个。那是他计划第二年过生日时纹的，他已经计划好了。”
So my father came home with it one day and he got it.
“所以有一天我父亲回家时就把它纹上了。”
You and your dad though, aren't the only ones?
“不过你和你父亲不是唯一的，对吧？”
No, there's me and my father, Steve [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. Mike [UNINTELLIGIBLE], who still works here. My grandmother has the sad face. Eric [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
“不，有我和我父亲，还有史蒂夫（纹了），还有依然在这里工作的迈克。我祖母也有那个哭脸。”
A tattoo?
“一个纹身？”
Yeah, she has it on her chest too. And Eric [UNINTELLIGIBLE] who worked here has it also.
“是的，她在胸口也有。在这里工作过的埃里克也有。”
And it's good. It's nice to see people. There's probably, all together, 15 people that have his name tattooed on them. We used to sit around the kitchen table and take a needle and wrap thread around it and dip it in calligraphy ink and tattoo each other with it. And there's quite a few people who we masterfully tattooed Chad's name on their arm. Whether they like it now or not, it's still there.
“这很好。很高兴看到人们纹。加起来可能有15个人身上纹了他的名字。我们过去常坐在餐桌旁，拿针缠上线，蘸上书法墨水，互相纹身。有很多人我们都巧妙地把查德的名字纹在他们手臂上。不管他们现在喜不喜欢，反正它就在那里。”
They've tried to stay as close to Chad's vision of the restaurant as possible. He never specified decor, so they've had a free hand there. He and Mike actually drafted a menu for the place. And the family has kept about half of it. The other half was slow baking recipes that no customer would ever wait for.
他们一直试图尽可能地保持查德对餐厅的构想。他从未指明装修风格，所以他们有自由发挥的空间。他和迈克其实为这个地方起草了一份菜单。家人保留了大约一半。另一半是那种没有任何顾客会等得及的慢烤食谱。
Chad was also a lot of fun, everyone says. A lot of fun. A comedian. And they say that's why they joke around so much at Chad's Trading Post. Scott says when he sees a heavy set customer that comes in a lot he says, hey Tubby. He builds towers of little creamer packages on the bald head of another customer. Glenn throws crumpled up napkins at his employees. They have water fights. All this levity in a place that's essentially a large roadside memorial that serves massive omelets.
大家都说，查德也非常有趣。非常有趣。是个喜剧天才。他们说这就是为什么他们在“查德的贸易站”里总是开玩笑的原因。斯科特说，当看到一个常来的肥胖顾客时，他会说：“嘿，胖子。”他会在另一个秃顶顾客的头上堆叠奶精小包。格伦会用揉成团的餐巾纸扔员工。他们会打水仗。这一切轻松感竟然发生在一个本质上是一个巨大的路边纪念碑、供应巨型煎蛋卷的地方。
If Chad was here, we'd have the place upside down by now.
“如果查德在这儿，我们早把这里翻个底朝天了。”
How do you mean?
“你是什么意思？”
Oh, it's in fun. We really have fun now. But I think if he was here, we wouldn't have all that tension of his passing on our shoulder. The only tension we'd have is, how much trouble are we going to get into?
“哦，只是闹着玩。我们现在真的很开心。但我认为如果他在，我们就不会有这种失去他的压力压在心头。我们唯一的压力就是：我们会惹出什么乱子？”
I have got to say, when I was here with Mary Ellen and we didn't know anything about the restaurant either. Obviously, we just found it. The first thing we saw was the menu and then we saw the back of Scott's shirt. And it was a little creepy, in a way.
我得说，当我和玛丽·埃伦来这儿时，我们对餐厅一无所知。我们只是发现了它。我们看到的第一件事是菜单，然后是斯科特衬衫背后的图案。从某种角度来说，确实有点诡异。
I've never gotten that response before, never gotten the response that that was creepy. I always got the response that that's a very nice thing to do. It's very genuine and it's heartwarming. I've never gotten creepy before.
“我以前从未得到过那样的反应，从没听过有人觉得这很诡异。我得到的反馈总是说这是一个非常好的做法。这非常真诚且暖心。我从未得到过‘诡异’的评价。”
Well, I just mean it's like there's somebody else here in the restaurant that's not really here. You know what I mean?
“不，我只是说，餐厅里好像有个人其实不在场。你知道我什么意思吗？”
And that's exactly what it is. He's here. He's here with us. And we kind of have to yell at him once in a while, because every time something silly or stupid happens, you've got to blame somebody. And he's one to pull a prank on me for that. He's definitely here. But there's nothing creepy about it.
“而这正是真相。他在。他在这里和我们在一起。我们偶尔得训斥他一下，因为每次发生傻事或蠢事时，你总得责怪某个人。他就是那种会对我搞恶作剧的人。他绝对在这里。但这没什么诡异的。”
I think I can safely say I have never seen any other family keep someone alive to this degree. They've gone out of their way to construct a world where they couldn't possibly forget Chad. A jumbo-sized photo of Chad stood behind Scott and his wife at their wedding. They believe Chad has protected their lives in serious accidents, that he brought Mike's son through a recent infection unscathed. Chad's room is the same as it was the day he was shot in it, with two exceptions. They took down the girlie pictures from the wall and they replaced the carpet.
我想我可以肯定地说，我从未见过其他家庭以这种程度让一个人“活着”。他们不遗余力地构建了一个不可能忘记查德的世界。查德的巨幅照片竖立在斯科特和妻子的婚礼上。他们相信查德在重大事故中保护了他们的生命，他让迈克的孩子免于感染。查德的房间和他被枪击那天一模一样，只有两个例外：他们取下了墙上的美女画，换了地毯。
Before they did all this, right after Chad died, they all say they were lost. Mike said he wanted to crawl into a hole. Scott and his father had to make a deal with each other that neither would kill himself. Scott and Cory went into counseling. Scott says it didn't help much.
在做这一切之前，查德刚死后，他们都说自己迷失了。迈克说他想钻进地洞里。斯科特和父亲达成协议，谁也不自杀。斯科特和科里参加了心理辅导。斯科特说这没多大用。
But that's how it was when it happened. You didn't know what to do. I had no idea what to do. I walked in the bathroom, I'd look in the mirror, and I'm staring at myself in the mirror. And I flipped out and started punching the mirror. So now both my hands are cut, and I'm bleeding all over the place, and sitting on the floor crying. And I have no idea why. When you're that old and something like that happens, you don't have any idea what to do in any circumstance.
“但事情发生时就是那样。你不知道该怎么办。我完全不知道该怎么办。我走进洗手间，看着镜子里的自己，我崩溃了，开始猛击镜子。现在我双手都被割破，血流满地，坐在地上哭。我根本不知道为什么。当你那个年纪，发生这种事时，你面对任何情况都束手无策。”
Walking across a bridge looking down. Yeah, maybe. You sit there and think about it for a few minutes. It takes a lot out of you. It takes a lot out of your mind. And counseling made it worse for a while.
“走在桥上往下看。是的，也许吧。你坐在那儿思考几分钟。这会耗尽你的精力。这会耗尽你的心智。咨询反而让情况变糟了一段时间。”
What made it better, what Glenn says saved them, was starting the family business, Chad's business.
格伦说拯救了他们、让他们好转的，是开始了这个家族企业，查德的生意。
I guess is it healthy? I mean, is it--
“我觉得这健康吗？我是说，这……”
I think everybody grieves in a different way. For me it is, because I'm doing something constructive. I was semi-retired and disabled before. I'm still disabled, but I was just vegging. I was sitting at home, feeling sorry for myself, and doing nothing. When the restaurant idea came up from his brother Scott, and we started looking into it rather seriously, we found the place, it was almost like a breath of fresh air. It was something we could all do in memory of his brother and have some fun with it. And we have for seven years.
“我认为每个人的悲伤方式都不同。对我来说这是健康的，因为我在做建设性的事情。我之前半退休且残疾了。我现在依然残疾，但当时我只是在混日子。我坐在家里自我怜悯，什么也不做。当他兄弟斯科特提出开餐馆的想法，我们开始认真研究，找到这个店址时，这几乎像是一股新鲜空气。这是我们可以为了纪念他兄弟而一起做的事情，并从中获得乐趣。七年来我们一直这么做。”
Healthy? I don't know. The psychiatrists say many different things. People who blithely say things will get better over time have never been here. Things never get better. They get a little less immediate. So we work this in memory of him as a way of keeping him immediate to us. Nobody forgets. We get along this way. We get by this way. The whole bunch of us get by this way.
“健康吗？我不知道。精神科医生说了各种各样的东西。那些轻率地说‘时间会治愈一切’的人从来没经历过这些。事情永远不会变好。它们只是变得没那么直接了。所以我们以纪念他的方式经营，这是一种让我们保持他与我们之间即时感的方式。没人会忘记。我们这样相处。我们这样度过难关。我们所有人都是这样过活的。”
In Northampton, where I used to live there was a couple, and they own a cafe. And at one point, they had a child who lived 19 days. And after they disconnected him from life support, they built a shrine in their restaurant for him. Pictures of him connected to white tubes dotted the walls and beams. And his father, a musician, would perform a song at the cafe-- weekly, as I remember it-- comparing his son to a [? salmon ?] and to the messiah. And some of us, at first, though we knew it had to be hard, felt a little embarrassed for them. As though this tragedy had driven them a little crazy.
在北安普顿，我以前住的地方有一对夫妇，他们开了一家咖啡馆。有一次，他们的孩子只活了19天。在拔掉生命维持系统后，他们在餐厅里为他建了一个神龛。插着白色管子的孩子照片点缀在墙壁和横梁上。他的父亲，一位音乐家，会每周在咖啡馆唱一首歌，将他的儿子比作一条鲑鱼和一个弥赛亚。我们中的一些人起初虽然知道这一定很难受，但还是为他们感到尴尬。仿佛这种悲剧让他们有点疯了。
I think it's hard for us to know exactly what to do or say when we see public mourning like this because we see it so rarely. The intensity of it is shocking. It's too naked. And usually we think that if you hold onto someone after their death this way, you can't live your own life. But clearly you can.
我想我们很难知道在看到这种公开哀悼时该做什么或说什么，因为我们很少见到它。这种强度令人震惊。它太赤裸了。通常我们认为，如果死后还以这种方式执着于某人，你就无法过自己的生活。但显然，你可以。
Sean Cole is a reporter at WBUR Radio in Boston. In the years since we first broadcast this story, Chad's Trading Post closed its doors. The family is keeping Chad's memory alive in a new restaurant, Chad's Good Table, 10 minutes away in Westfield, Massachusetts.
肖恩·科尔是波士顿WBUR广播电台的记者。自我们首次播出这个故事以来的几年里，“查德的贸易站”关门了。这个家庭在10分钟路程外的韦斯特菲尔德开设了一家新餐馆，“查德的好餐桌”，继续纪念查德。
[MUSIC- "WITHOUT YOU" BY MOTLEY CRUE]
[音乐：Motley Crue的《Without You》]
Coming up, what's more dangerous, a borrowed military vehicle filled with family members or the rough and tumble world of the cleaning supply business? That's in a minute, from Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，什么更危险，一辆装满家庭成员的借来的军用车辆，还是尔虞我诈的清洁用品生意？一分钟后，在我们的节目继续时为您揭晓，来自公共广播国际台。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, invite a variety of different people to take a whack at that theme with different kinds of stories. Today's program, family businesses, what happens when blood has to handle money. We have arrived at Act Three of our program. Act Three, Family Photo Opp.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会选择一个主题，邀请不同的人用各种故事来探讨这个主题。今天的节目是家族企业，当血缘必须处理金钱时会发生什么。我们已经进入了节目的第三幕。《家庭合影》。
This is the story of a family that lurched briefly into a new business, the business of politics.
这是一个家庭短暂闯入一个新行业——政治行业的故事。
Bill Eggers was 31, working for a free market think tank in Los Angeles, consulting with mayors, governors, and future presidents about privatizing and downsizing government services. He wrote a book on the subject, which Newt Gingrich endorsed on the cover at a time when that endorsement meant a whole lot. And then, well, his brother Dave tells what happened next.
比尔·艾格斯31岁，在洛杉矶一家自由市场智库工作，为市长、州长和未来的总统提供关于私有化和精简政府服务的咨询。他写了一本关于这个主题的书，纽特·金里奇在封面上为它背书，在当时那意味着很大的影响力。然后，嗯，他的兄弟戴夫讲述了接下来的故事。
No one is caring about the Hummer. We are driving by, smooth and shiny, but no one is caring. It is bright red, this Hummer. And is powerful and gorgeous, this Hummer. And we are driving it slow, its wheels new and inky black, through Manhattan Beach, through Redondo Beach, past the boardwalks and t-shirt shops and retailers of frog-shaped paper weights fashioned from seashells. And while we are driving, we are waving and honking gently. And every so often we are saying, vote for Eggers, because my brother Bill is running for state representative and the election is tomorrow.
没人关心那辆悍马。我们开着它经过，它光滑闪亮，但没人关心。这辆悍马是亮红色的。它强大而华丽。我们缓慢地开着它，轮子是全新的深墨黑色，穿过曼哈顿海滩，穿过雷东多海滩，经过木板路、T恤店和兜售贝壳制成青蛙形镇纸的零售商。当我们开车时，我们在挥手，轻按喇叭。每隔一段时间我们就会说：“投艾格斯一票”，因为我兄弟比尔正在竞选州代表，明天就是选举日。
The day is watercolor blue and I am with Bill, my younger brother, Toph, and this guy, Kevin, Bill's best friend from college who has taken a few weeks leave from his job as a toilet paper sales rep to help with the campaign's homestretch. This is the fall of 1998, and Bill is running in California's South Bay, just below Los Angeles, as a Republican against someone named George Nakano, a Democratic incumbent.
天空是水彩蓝，我和比尔、我弟弟托夫，还有那个叫凯文的家伙在一起。凯文是比尔大学时的死党，他请了几周假，放下手头卫生纸销售员的工作来帮忙竞选的最后冲刺。这是1998年的秋天，比尔在洛杉矶南部的加州南湾区参选，作为共和党人挑战一位名叫乔治·中野的民主党在任者。
Kevin is driving us around in a Humvee because we are quite sure-- who could doubt it-- that everyone will like the Hummer, it being red and wide and shiny, imperious and yet oddly whimsical. They will like the Hummer and will then like my brother and will vote for him and he win.
凯文开着悍马带我们四处转，因为我们非常肯定——谁会怀疑呢——每个人都会喜欢这辆悍马，它又红又宽又亮，傲慢又莫名地异想天开。他们会喜欢悍马，然后会喜欢我兄弟，然后会投他一票，他就赢了。
We drive through an office park where a group of men in white shirts and ties are eating their lunch. They look at the Hummer as we go by. They are first surprised, surely by the startling beauty and power of this vehicle. And then they look at the signs papering the Hummer's sides, those bearing my brother's name. Then they go back to eating their lunch. Kevin waves. They were definitely impressed, he says. That's three votes right there, Bill says. We all laugh. Campaigns are fun.
我们穿过一个办公园区，一群穿白衬衫打领带的男人们在吃午饭。我们经过时他们看着悍马。他们首先感到惊讶，肯定是为这辆车的惊人美感和力量。然后他们看了看贴在悍马侧面的标志，那些印着我兄弟名字的标志。然后他们继续吃午饭。凯文挥了挥手。“他们绝对印象深刻，”他说。“那就有三票了，”比尔说。我们都笑了。竞选很有趣。
We came out from New York for this. Bill had been asking gently for weeks if there was any way Toph and I could come out for the election. After telling him that we couldn't possibly make it-- Toph was right in the middle of his sophomore year in high school-- finally, we surprised him, flew out to help with the last couple days of the campaign.
我们从纽约赶来就是为了这个。比尔几周来一直温和地询问托夫和我是否能回来参加选举。在告诉他我们不可能赶过来——托夫正处于高二学年的中间——最后，我们给了他一个惊喜，飞过来帮他度过竞选的最后几天。
When we got to LA, we were prepared for Bill to be edgy, wired with worry-- the details, the last minute polls, phone calls, all the money he had spent. The cumulative weight of a yearlong campaign. But then as were waiting for our luggage, Bill crept up behind us. Boo, he yelled, grabbing us both around the neck, then holding us in a double headlock, roaring. Good lord, there was no way we expected him to pick us up at the airport.
当我们到达洛杉矶时，我们以为比尔会显得急躁、焦虑——细节、最后一刻的民调、电话、他花掉的所有钱。一年竞选的累积压力。但当我们在等行李时，比尔悄悄走到我们身后。“嘘！”他大喊，抓住我们的脖子，然后把我们俩勒进双人锁喉，咆哮着。天哪，我们完全没想到他会亲自来机场接我们。
Didn't he have better things to do? Wouldn't he be desperately running from house to house yelling his name, bursting into crowded restaurants, reminding people of his presence? His message? His destiny? No, he was picking us up at the airport, in his convertible, in a polo shirt and khakis.
他没有更重要的事要做吗？他难道不该绝望地挨家挨户大喊自己的名字，冲进挤满人的餐馆，提醒人们他的存在？他的信息？他的命运？不，他在机场接我们，开着敞篷车，穿着Polo衫和卡其裤。
As we left airport and slid into the highway, I asked how things looked odds-wise.
当我们离开机场驶入高速公路时，我问他胜算如何。
Well, it's hard to tell, he said. Hard to tell. Hard to tell. Hey, you guys hungry? We should get us some burritos or something. So we got us some burritos.
“嗯，很难说，”他说。“很难说。很难说。嘿，你们饿吗？我们应该去买点墨西哥卷饼之类的。”所以我们去买了卷饼。
Whoop, someone just noticed the Hummer. An older man walking in the crosswalk in front of us, himself in khakis and a polo shirt, just saw the signs and waved. We all waved back. Vote tomorrow, Kevin yells out the window. The man gives a thumbs up.
“喔，有人注意到悍马了。”一个走在斑马线上的老年人，他也穿着卡其裤和Polo衫，看到了标志并挥了挥手。我们都挥手回应。“明天去投票！”凯文从窗口大喊。那个人竖起了大拇指。
Kevin drives slow, honks repeatedly. He and Bill are waving. There is little in the way of waving back. Kevin debates whether he should be honking more, or maybe driving faster or slower. We all agree that so far his driving is fine, but that in the future, we need to be more discerning about the route.
凯文开得很慢，不断按喇叭。他和比尔在挥手。回应的人很少。凯文讨论着他是否应该多按喇叭，或者也许该开快点还是慢点。我们都同意到目前为止他的开车还可以，但以后我们需要更谨慎地选择路线。
For example, the trip through the high school parking lot might have been a bit unnecessary, so few of those kids being of voting age. Yeah, but the kids love the Hummer, he says. And it's true. Kids love the Hummer.
例如，穿过高中停车场的行程可能有点没必要，因为那些孩子很少有达到投票年龄的。是的，但孩子们喜欢悍马，他说。这是真的。孩子们喜欢悍马。
Midway through the campaign, even after garnering endorsements from Pete Wilson, Milton Friedman, and Drew Carey, even after one of Bill's consultants had linked his opponent, Nakano, to everything from drugs in schools to death of cancer patients to various bus accidents, Bill was still lagging about a dozen or so points behind. There was all kinds of speculation why.
竞选中期，即使在获得了皮特·威尔逊、米尔顿·弗里德曼和德鲁·凯里的背书后，即使在比尔的一位顾问将他的对手中野与从校园毒品到癌症患者死亡再到各种公交事故的一切联系起来之后，比尔仍然落后大约十几个百分点。关于原因有各种猜测。
Maybe Bill seemed too academic, too wonky. Maybe the anti-Republican sentiment-- this was just after the impeachment, remember-- was rubbing off on poor Bill. And maybe it was because Bill seemed rootless, lacking that comforting one of us feeling.
也许比尔显得太学术，太书呆子气。也许反共和党情绪——记住，那是在弹劾之后——影响了可怜的比尔。也许是因为比尔看起来像个无根之人，缺乏那种令人宽慰的“我们自己人”的感觉。
He was single, had grown up in Chicago. Had no kids in the schools. Didn't own a house. While Nakano was 60ish, a married man with children, a mortgage, a rock garden, everything.
他是单身，在芝加哥长大。学校里没有孩子。没有房产。而中野60多岁，已婚，有孩子，有抵押贷款，有岩石花园，应有尽有。
Thus began a process of shoring up Bill's family side, a process that Bill entered reluctantly. My older sister Beth and I signed our name to a flyer that talked about how much Bill had helped out with the raising of young Toph since our parents passed on seven years earlier. And how the values instilled by our mom and dad-- may they rest in peace, sniff, sniff-- were being respected and carried out by Bill. And how he wanted only to create a community fit for the family he soon hoped to have, et cetera, et cetera. You get the idea.
于是开始了一个修补比尔“家庭形象”的过程，比尔对此很勉强。我的大姐贝丝和我联名签署了一份传单，谈论自从我们的父母七年前去世后，比尔在抚养小托夫的过程中给予了多少帮助。以及我们妈妈和爸爸灌输的价值观——愿他们安息，抽泣，抽泣——是如何被比尔尊重和贯彻的。以及他想为他希望很快拥有的家庭创造一个合适的社区，等等等等。你们明白意思。
And though Bill was nervous at first about whether or not Beth and I would lend our names to the campaign, given that politically I'm far left of Bill, and Beth's far left of me, neither of us blinked really, didn't think twice.
虽然比尔起初很紧张我和贝丝是否会把名字借给竞选，但考虑到政治上我远比比尔左倾，贝丝又远比我左倾，我们俩真的都没眨眼，没多想。
First of all, I had never in my life known the name of my own state representative. So I figured the office was mostly for the entertainment and advancement of its holder. Thus, the damage Bill could do would be pretty minimal.
首先，我这辈子从不知道自己州代表的名字。所以我认为这个职位主要是为了持有人娱乐和晋升。因此，比尔能造成的损害将非常有限。
In the Hummer, we drive through a major intersection, six lanes. A mall on one side, condos on the other. Bill points to the median. That's it. That's where I had to stand.
在悍马车里，我们穿过一个主要十字路口，六车道。一边是购物中心，另一边是公寓。比尔指着中间隔离带。“就是那儿。我得站在那儿。”
What do you mean, Toph asks.
“什么意思？”托夫问。
The consultants said I had to go out there and stand, waving to the cars going by. I did it three times, six hours each time waving to every car.
“顾问们说我必须去那儿站着，向经过的车挥手。我做了三次，每次六小时，向每一辆车挥手。”
We discussed this. We were often discussing the wisdom of the consultants' various ideas and initiatives. I'm beginning to wonder just how good these consultants could be if they think a candidate should be standing in the middle of a highway in a suit waving to people on their way to Radio Shack. This was endearing? This commanded the respect of voters?
我们讨论了这个问题。我们经常讨论顾问们的各种想法和举措的智慧。我开始怀疑这些顾问到底能有多好，如果他们认为候选人应该穿着西装站在高速公路中间，向去Radio Shack买东西的人挥手。这很讨人喜欢？这赢得了选民的尊重？
Maybe they'll feel bad for you, Toph says. Bill laughs. He's been laughing a lot lately. This campaign has been killing him.
“也许他们会同情你，”托夫说。比尔笑了。他最近笑得很多。这次竞选快把他杀死了。
A few years ago, Bill lent his name to a conference in DC, one centered around the discussion of exactly where private companies might fit in should welfare or portions of its processes be privatized. Now, the conference was not planned so well. A meeting about poor people held at the swank Park Hyatt and costing $1,300 per participant. It was a PR nightmare. And easy pickings for someone like liberal bon vivant, Barbara Ehrenreich, who oozed in with an article more or less written before she darkened the doorway.
几年前，比尔为华盛顿举行的一个会议背书，会议讨论如果福利或其部分流程私有化，私人公司究竟应该处于什么位置。现在，会议计划得不怎么样。一个关于穷人的会议在豪华的柏悦酒店举行，每位参与者收费1300美元。这是一场公关噩梦。对于像自由派美食家芭芭拉·埃伦瑞奇这样的人来说，这是轻松的猎物，她写了一篇在走进门口之前就基本写好的文章。
And after lambasting the whole affair, quite effectively and often justly by the way, she saved some of her most condescending vitriol for Bill, who never saw it coming. She describes him shrugging off policy questions while turning to his dessert. A quote, "Five inch high structure of ice cream and chocolate. Now dribbling promiscuously into a brown and white pool," end quote. Nice job, if obviously the work of a journalist desperately stretching an anecdote to fill a metaphorical void.
在猛烈抨击了整个事件后——顺便说一句，非常有效且往往是正义的——她将最刻薄的恶语留给了比尔，比尔根本没预料到。她描述他耸耸肩撇开政策问题，转向他的甜点。引文：“五英寸高的冰淇淋和巧克力结构。现在正猥亵地滴入一滩棕白色的池塘里，”引号结束。干得好，如果这明显是一个记者为了填补隐喻空白而绝望地延伸轶事的话。
When he saw it, Bill couldn't believe it. He was angry and hurt, but nowhere near as angry as I was.
当他看到它时，比尔简直不敢相信。他很生气也很受伤，但远没有我那么生气。
You have got to help me write a response, he said.
“你必须帮我写个回应，”他说。
Yes, yes, please, I said. So we spent a few days working together on a letter. And oh, man, did I have some ideas.
“是的，是的，请，”我说。所以我们花了几天一起写信。天哪，我可有不少点子。
First, we'd call the fact checkers and tear the thing to shreds. Was the cake really five inches high? Was it served as she claims just as she asked him about welfare, or was it slightly before? Did the ice cream really dribble promiscuously?
首先，我们会打电话给事实核查员，把那篇文章撕得粉碎。那块蛋糕真的有五英寸高吗？它是像她声称的那样在她问他福利问题时送上的，还是稍微早一点？那冰淇淋真的“猥亵地”滴落了吗？
Then we'd dig into her other factual problems, then her politics, her agenda going in. Never mind that I had written the same kinds of articles, that I wasn't exactly on Bill's side of this issue, and that her piece was, for the most part, dead on. She had taken on the wrong family. Will the Eggers name be tarnished in the pages of Harper's magazine? No. The answer is no.
然后我们会深挖她其他的事实问题，她的政治，她带着议程入场。别介意我写过同样的文章，我并不完全站在比尔这边，而且她的文章在很大程度上是准确的。她惹错了家庭。艾格斯的姓氏会在《哈珀》杂志的页面上蒙羞吗？不。答案是不。
So I drafted a withering response, laser accurate and dripping with condescension. Every time I sat down, I added to it, injected more venom, more dismissals. She would cry. Her children would cry. Her pets would roll over and moan with agony.
所以我起草了一份刻薄的回应，激光般精确，滴着刻薄的 condescension（傲慢）。我每次坐下来都会补充，注入更多毒液，更多不屑。她会哭。她的孩子们会哭。她的宠物会翻身发出痛苦的呻吟。
But when I sent it to Bill for his approval, he had already gotten over it. I was still boiling, but he wasn't really mad anymore. He had put together his own letter, dry and curt, correcting a few facts and leaving it at that.
但当我把它发给比尔征求批准时，他已经不介意了。我还在沸腾，但他已经不生气了。他自己写了一封信，干燥而生硬，纠正了几个事实，然后就此作罢。
It drove me nuts. If only he had left it to me, the letter and now this campaign. The flyers? I could've done them better. The events I could've done better. The media relations surely. The mailers, the phone calls, the reminders. His brother should have been doing them. I should have come out for the campaign, the whole thing. Only I could have done it right. Only family knows how to sell family. There's a reason these things stay in the family and it has to do with passion and loyalty, ferocious loyalty. We would brand our family's values, bring them to a grateful LA, and then a grateful nation. We would be the Kennedys, the Bushs. I would be Bay Buchanan.
这让我抓狂。要是他把这件事交给我，这封信，现在还有这场竞选。传单？我本可以做得更好。活动我本可以做得更好。媒体关系肯定也是。邮件、电话、提醒。他兄弟本该做这些。我本该回来参加竞选，全程负责。只有我能把它做对。只有家人知道如何推销家人。这些事情留在家庭内部是有原因的，这与激情和忠诚有关，凶猛的忠诚。我们会给家庭价值观贴上品牌，带给感恩的洛杉矶，然后是一个感恩的国家。我们会成为肯尼迪家族，布什家族。我会是贝·布坎南。
Kevin and Bill drop us off at the beach, so Toph and I can swim before sunset. Then they head back to headquarters to supervise the final phone bank, where they'll warn voters one last time that a vote for George Nakano will be a vote for corruption, the mafia, bus accidents, and drugs in the hands of all children over four. Tomorrow they will vote and Bill will not win. We'll go down to Manhattan's this cedary kind of bar and restaurant where we'll watch the results come in.
凯文和比尔把我们扔在海滩上，让托夫和我可以在日落前游泳。然后他们回到总部监督最后的电话银行，他们将在那里最后一次警告选民，投乔治·中野一票将是投给腐败、黑手党、公交车事故和毒品，落入所有四岁以上孩子的手中。明天他们会投票，比尔不会赢。我们会去曼哈顿那家类似雪松的酒吧和餐馆看结果出来。
Toph and I will be wearing our khakis and light blue button downs, and we'll walk around and chat with the volunteers. On the big screen TV, the results for Bill's race will be shown infrequently. Buried between those for Senate, House, governorships. We will see Bill's returns when only 2% or 3% of the precincts have reported. Then we'll stand around for a while longer. And then suddenly his returns will be shown again, and the words on the screen will say that Eggers lost.
托夫和我会穿着卡其裤和浅蓝色扣领衬衫，我们会走来走去和志愿者聊天。在大屏幕电视上，比尔竞选的结果不常出现。埋在参议院、众议院、州长职位的竞争结果之间。我们会在只有2%或3%的选区报告时看到比尔的回报。然后我们会再站一会儿。然后突然他的回报再次显示，屏幕上的文字将显示艾格斯输了。
Later, I will find Bill downstairs alone, in his suit, with his young face watching a bank of TVs.
后来，我会发现比尔独自在楼下，穿着西装，带着他年轻的面孔看着一排电视。
I'm sorry, I will say.
“我很抱歉，”我会说。
It's OK, he'll say. I knew it a while ago.
“没关系，”他会说。“我刚才就知道了。”
But why didn't you say so, I'll say. Why did you want us to come all the way out if you knew you were going to lose?
“但你为什么不说出来，”我会说。“你既然知道要输，为什么还要我们大老远跑过来？”
My brother has a beautiful smile.
我兄弟有着美丽的笑容。
Dave Eggers is the editor of McSweeney's at mcsweeneys.net. William Eggers is now a senior fellow at the New York based Manhattan Institute for Policy Research. He's the author of two new books on transforming government. Most recent, Government 2.0.
戴夫·艾格斯是mcsweeneys.net上《麦克斯韦尼》的编辑。威廉·艾格斯现在是纽约曼哈顿政策研究所的高级研究员。他是两本关于改革政府的新书的作者。最近的一本是《政府2.0》。
Act Four, Every Unhappy Family Cleaning Supply Business is Unhappy in Its Own Way. People who study family businesses say that one of the biggest problems those companies face is the problem of secession. What happens when the younger generation comes into the business? These conflicts can last decades. This happened in Hillary Frank's family.
第四幕，《每个不幸的清洁用品生意家庭都有其各自的不幸》。研究家族企业的人说，这些公司面临的最大问题之一是继承问题。当年轻一代进入企业时会发生什么？这些冲突可能会持续几十年。这发生在希拉里·弗兰克的家庭中。
My grandfather and his brother stopped speaking to their sister in 1963. I've seen old tin type photographs of her as a young woman, but I have never met my great aunt or anyone in her family.
我祖父和他的兄弟在1963年停止了与他们姐妹的交谈。我见过她年轻时的旧锡板照片，但我从未见过我的姑婆或她家里的任何人。
When I ask family members what happened, the answers are always foggy. Nobody seems to know exactly what happened. Something in the family business.
当我问家人们发生了什么时，答案总是模糊的。没人似乎知道究竟发生了什么。生意里的一些事情。
The only living character from this shrouded past on the side of the family we still speak to is Mo, my grandfather's brother, my great uncle. He got in the business in the '30s. The trouble began after his nephew was hired.
我们家目前唯一活着的、经历过那段被遮蔽的历史的人是莫，我祖父的兄弟，我的伯祖父。他在30年代进入了这行。麻烦始于他侄子被雇佣之后。
He was my protege. I was grooming him. He started out working in the warehouse. I was trying to teach him all the things that I knew and trying to get him into a role where at some point he could run that business.
“他是我的门徒。我在培养他。他开始是在仓库工作。我试图教他我所知道的一切，试图让他进入某个角色，以便在某个时候他能经营那家生意。”
Mo was in charge of the sales department. There were two or three salesman who worked under him.
莫负责销售部。有两三名推销员在他手下工作。
Your grandfather came in in a slot that he was not qualified for. Had absolutely no right to be in that business. He was too nice a man. He had other interests that did not include the wear and tear of a dog-eat-dog business. And the other people felt that he was holding up progress, and probably felt that for the money he was drawing, for the work he was doing, it was not a good deal for the business. I was protecting him all the time.
“你祖父进来的位置他并不够格。在那家生意里绝对没有理由。他是个太好的人。他有其他兴趣，不包括这种狗咬狗生意的磨损。其他人觉得他在阻碍进展，可能觉得对于他拿的薪水、做的活儿来说，这对生意不是笔好买卖。我一直在保护他。”
One day in 1963, Mo got a letter from his nephew calling for a special meeting. Mo says this was unheard of in their business. He was certain that they were going to reduce his authority and fire my grandfather. So he and my grandfather never showed up at the meeting. He never discussed it with his nephew.
1963年的一天，莫收到了他侄子要求召开特别会议的信。莫说这在他们的生意里是闻所未闻的。他肯定他们要削减他的权限并解雇我祖父。所以他和祖父从没在会议上露面。他从未与侄子讨论过。
The treachery involved to me was the biggest factor. What I resented was the fact that my nephew, whom I had tutored, did not have the need or the desire to come and talk to me. Say, look, Uncle, let's talk about this thing. We're running a business here, not a family society. I could have understood that rather than a cold letter announcing a meeting. To me, that was a knife in my back from my nephew.
“对我来说，背叛是最大的因素。我所愤恨的是，我辅导的侄子竟然没有需要或愿望来和我谈谈。说，‘看，叔叔，让我们谈谈这件事。我们是在经营生意，不是家庭社团。’我本可以理解这一点，而不是一封宣布会议的冷冰冰的信。对我来说，那是侄子捅在我背上的一刀。”
And I got mad enough to say, I never liked this business in the first place. And if I can get out now with my brother while the getting out is good, we'll do it. And within a month, we were out of there.
“我气得够呛，我说：‘我本来就不喜欢这行。如果我现在能和我兄弟一起退出，只要退出条件好，我们就做。’一个月内，我们就退出那儿了。”
Everyone in the family has a different version of this story and who is in the wrong. You hear that Mo wanted to get out of the business anyway, that their side of the family blames the wives, not the men, for the following out.
家里每个人对这个故事都有不同的版本，关于谁做错了。你听说莫本来就想退出生意，他们那边的家庭责怪妻子们，而不是男人，导致了分裂。
The story I heard from my mother growing up is radically different from Mo's version.
我妈长大时听到的故事和莫的版本截然不同。
It's very hard to imagine that my father was so ineffectual in his job that he needed to be protected. I know that he was a conscientious businessman. And it's also hard for me to understand, because I've spent all these years under the belief that it was my uncle who was being pushed out and it was my father who left in support of him.
“很难想象我父亲在工作中如此无能以至于需要被保护。我知道他是一个尽责的商人。而且我也很难理解，因为我多年来一直相信是被我叔叔踢出去了，而我父亲是支持他才离开的。”
You know, part of the mystique of this whole incident is that nobody really seems to understand what happened. And yet, it caused so much pain.
“你知道，整个事件的神秘感就在于没人真正了解发生了什么。然而，它造成了这么多痛苦。”
Shortly after we got out, I got an invitation to my nephew's son's bar mitzvah. I remember, in big red ink, writing on the invitation and sending it back, "Judas." Never attended the bar mitzvah. Never spoke to him again. Never spoke to my sister again.
“我们出来后不久，我收到了侄子儿子成年礼的邀请。我记得，用大红墨水在邀请函上写着‘犹大’并寄了回去。从没参加那个成年礼。再也没和他说过话。再也没和我姐妹说过话。”
The greatest effect that this had on the family was that my father had a heart attack a few months after the family dispute. It was pretty clear to everyone in the family that stress that he experienced, which was major, was a direct line cause of the heart attack.
“这给家庭造成的最大影响是，我父亲在家庭纠纷发生几个月后得了心脏病。家里每个人都很清楚，他经历的那种压力非常大，是导致心脏病的直接原因。”
The stress my mother is talking about had to do with family tension and what it's like to start over when you're 50. But mostly, it had to do with money. My grandfather was unemployed for two years. For the first time in his life, he was clipping coupons. He built his own storm windows from plastic sheeting and pieces of wood he found.
我母亲谈论的压力与家庭紧张有关，以及当你50岁时重新开始是什么感觉。但主要是关于钱。我祖父失业了两年。他这辈子第一次开始剪优惠券。他用塑料布和找到的木头制作了自己的防风窗。
My mother was 17 when he left the business and had planned on applying to Ivy League schools, but ended up having to go to the free city college instead. And the family blamed my grandfather's sister.
我母亲离开生意时17岁，本来打算申请常春藤盟校，但最终不得不去免费的城市学院。家人把这归咎于我祖父的姐妹。
Oh, bitterness is not the word. There was anger that was fostered and nurtured in that house every single day to the tune of a Jewish expression that my grandmother had that translates to a fire on her. The "her" being referred to was my aunt.
“哦，苦涩不足以形容。在那所房子里，每天都会有人培育和滋养愤怒，唱着我祖母的一句意第绪语表达，翻译过来就是‘火烧她’。‘她’指的是我姑婆。”
For example, my grandmother was a really expert cook and baker. And she was cooking on a stove in my parents' house that was really on its last legs. And they talked about what kind of stove they could afford and if my grandmother was present for this conversation she would have said, a fire [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. There was always a direct relationship between what we couldn't afford and whose fault it was.
“例如，我祖母是一位非常专业的厨师和面包师。她在父母家里那台真的快要报废的炉子上做饭。他们讨论买得起什么样的炉子，如果我祖母在场参与这个对话，她会说：‘火烧她’。我们买不起的东西和是谁的错之间总是有着直接的联系。”
Mo didn't talk to his sister or nephew for 35 years. Finally, when Mo's sister was, at the age of 90, going in for heart surgery, he got in touch with her. It took another year before he could bring himself to forgive his nephew.
莫35年没和他的姐妹或侄子说过话。最终，当莫的姐妹90岁高龄要进行心脏手术时，他与她取得了联系。又过了一年，他才能够说服自己原谅侄子。
I feel that I underwent a catharsis. I cleaned out of my system something insidious that was hurting me, which was my anger. I got rid of that. Life is short. You get to be this age, how many more years do you have? Why waste them on something that's not productive for happiness? Concentrate on the good things. But in self-analysis and self-evaluation I ask myself this question. If I had not done as well financially as I have done in the last three, four years, would I have reconciled? Would I not have remembered the bitterness? It was easier to reconcile with a full stomach.
“我觉得我经历了一次宣泄。我清理掉了系统里一些阴险的东西，那东西在伤害我，那就是我的愤怒。我摆脱了它。生命短暂。你到了这个年纪，还有多少年？为什么要把它们浪费在对幸福没有生产力的事情上？专注于好的事情。但在自我分析和自我评估中，我问自己这个问题：如果我在过去三四年里没有做得那么好，我会和解吗？我不会记住那份苦涩吗？肚子饱了之后再和解更容易。”
Mo's been trying to get my mother to reconcile as well, but she doesn't want to.
莫一直试图让我母亲也和解，但她不想。
We don't really see eye to eye in terms of this reconciliation. I don't feel any void in my life in not being in touch with the people who caused my parents and my grandmother and me so much pain.
“我们在和解方面并没有达成一致。我觉得即使不与那些给我的父母、祖母和我带来这么多痛苦的人联系，我的生活也没有缺失。”
Do you still feel angry?
“你还觉得生气吗？”
I've gotten to the point where I feel indifferent. And I also feel a sense of loyalty to my parents. I think it would be presumptuous of me to supersede my parents in a way. And beside that, it was important for me to make peace with people that they were content to be alienated from.
“我已经达到了感到冷漠的地步。而且我也对父母有一种忠诚感。我觉得超越我的父母以某种方式这样做是冒昧的。除此之外，与他们满足于疏远的人讲和对我来说并不重要。”
This is like a lot of family conflicts. One generation carries its anger to the grave, or maybe takes the time to reconcile. But the children are a generation removed from the battle. Across that distance, anger can turn to indifference. And by the time it gets to the third generation, my generation, it's just an interesting story.
这就像许多家庭冲突一样。一代人把愤怒带进坟墓，或者也许花时间去和解。但孩子们是距离战斗一代之遥的。跨过那个距离，愤怒可以转变为冷漠。等到第三代，也就是我这一代，它只是一个有趣的故事。
Hil, can I say one thing? The other thing about the family business is that my parents met there. My father used to tell the tale that he was walking in the warehouse, and he tripped over a bolt, and that my mother, who was the secretary of the business, happened to be there. And she came to his rescue, and saved him, and picked him up. And that's how they met.
“希尔，我能说一件事吗？关于家族企业的另一件事是，我父母在那里认识。我父亲常说他走在仓库里时，被一个螺栓绊倒了，而当时担任生意秘书的母亲碰巧在那里。她救了他，把他扶了起来。这就是他们认识的方式。”
How romantic.
“多浪漫。”
It's very romantic. And that was the most wonderful thing that came out of that business.
“那确实非常浪漫。那是从那家生意里出来的最美好的事情。”
Hillary Frank. When she's not doing radio stories, she writes novels for young people. Her most recent is called, I Can't Tell You.
希拉里·弗兰克。当她不做广播故事时，她写青少年小说。她最近的一本小说叫《我不能告诉你》。
[MUSIC- "TWO STORY HOUSE" BY GEORGE JONES AND TAMMY WYNETTE]
[音乐：George Jones和Tammy Wynette的《Two Story House》]
Well, our program was produced today by Susan Burton and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Blue Chevigny, Julie Snyder, and Nancy Updike. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Starlee Kine. Elizabeth Meister runs our website.
我们的节目今天由苏珊·伯顿和我制作，还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格、布鲁·切维尼、朱莉·斯奈德和南希·厄普代克。托德·巴赫曼和斯塔莉·凯恩提供了制作帮助。伊丽莎白·迈斯特负责我们的网站。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, www.thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our programs for absolutely free 24 hours a day. Or you can download audio of our program at audible.com/thisamericanlife, where they have public radio programs, bestselling books, even the New York Times all at audible.com.
我们的网站是www.thisamericanlife.org，在那里您可以免费收听我们的节目，每天24小时。或者您可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife下载我们的节目音频，那里有公共广播节目、畅销书，甚至《纽约时报》，都在audible.com。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由公共广播国际台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金赞助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia, who describes the family that is WBEZ this way--
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他这样描述WBEZ这个大家庭——
People who blithely say things will get better over time have never been here. Things never get better.
“那些轻率地说‘时间会治愈一切’的人从来没经历过这些。事情永远不会变好。”
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际台。